we're at this critical moment this time
right now to decide the future of our
society
my name is Dallas call tooth I'm an
organizer with the indigenous
environmental network I'm a Dakota man
from the Lower South Dakota nation and
so called Minnesota the world's getting
hotter and the only way the most direct
effective way to stop global temperature
rise is to keep fossil fuels in the
ground that's it in the worst case
scenario of a spill you have a highly
pressurized crude oil that could spill
out at thousands of thousands of gallons
per minute you could see a lot of oil
that could be going in to not only the
river system itself but into the aquifer
that provides the act of the wells for a
lot of homes in the area that provides
the wells for agriculture and for cattle
feed so the worst-case scenario is a
disaster
this movement is not a movement out of
hate but pure and simple a movement out
of love there is this one night in camp
just at sunset and I'm standing on a
large hill that's overlooking the camp
and I'm hearing songs from four
different tribal nations from Bor
entirely different places across Turtle
Island I'm hearing music from the
Pacific Northwest native people from the
Pacific Northwest from folks from the
from the Gulf Coast from the East Coast
and all these songs are expressions of
love for the water it's a fight beyond
us it's something greater than us it's a
fight to protect mother earth overall a
fight to protect the sacred integrity of
Mother Earth and that spiritual essence
of her lifeblood the water and that
happens on a nightly basis of song and
prayer and resistance we're at this
critical moment as time right now to
decide the future of our society whether
we want to stay addicted to this fossil
fuel regime to this colonial system that
is predicated on the oppression of our
people that makes us believe that we
need more fossil fuels it's a false
narrative we're in a time right now
where we can see a just transition
towards a sustainable renewable energy
system and it just takes action and so
that's what we're seeing right now on
the ground is action
I do it for my kids by my efforts by the
work that I'm doing hopefully I can
create something better for them a world
more just the world more sustainable
than what I grew up in and if I can do
that
that's this mission accomplished that's
that's that's my hope my dream